das ist echt extrem viel
also mir leute ganz ehrlich mir wird
jetzt persönlich gerade in diesem moment
übel
servus skates und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich nicht nur
ein hemd an habe das wahrscheinlich mein
opa schon getragen hat auch zwei weitere
gegenstände kommen heute zum einsatz und
zwar dass hier
und das hier das ist eineinhalb liter
flasche mit wasser und das andere ist
ein leeres glas
wie kommt das alles zusammenhängt
wir machen heute eine change die
eigentlich ein klassiker unter den
challenges ist die orca reisen schwert
sehr nice deshalb traumstadt ein
klassiker in genesis und zwar die ein
glas wasser pro kilo challenge die hat
der liebe simon gespielt auch damals mal
gemacht in seiner challenge serie
habt ihr vielleicht gesehen falls nicht
oder falls sich über mal anschauen
wollte habe ich ihr euch unten verlinkt
natürlich weil derjenige der die idee
hat muss auch der quelle dafür bekommen
hier geht's los mit diesem typen romans
denen ich würde sagen es sieht gut aus
und es wäre okay sehr schön ein glas
wasser trinken
schnell mal einschenken alter wer kommt
nicht weg klagt ich kann nichts machen
ich habe keine chance
ich sollte mir die gläser schnell auch
mal vor einschenken wo jetzt erst los
das problem dabei ist dass ich heute
nicht viel getrunken hat aber extrem
viel gegessen das heißt ich habe schon
richtig vollen magen max hat am morgen
nämlich frühstück geholt hat so
reingehauen jetzt so viel mitgebracht
mango maracuja gulasch lachsfilet
brötchen so streusel teilchen gefühl mit
vanillecreme und puderzucker bestäubt
was noch brötchen kaffee mit zucker ist
was sich also ich hab mich morgen beim
frühstück total gekillt mit dem was
gegessen habe aber es war richtig geil
und jetzt habe ich die reste des
frühstücks gerade eben noch essen
ich bin richtig richtig satt und ja mein
magen es entsprechend voll heißt das
könnte natürlich probleme geben wenn ich
mir jetzt also extrem viel wasser dar
ein fülle
denn davon ist schon der nächste gegner
da gehen wir auch direkt mal drauf ich
dachte schon eröffnet und wieder dürfen
der kommt nicht raus und wir haben ihn
so kurz war uns irgendwo hinstellen wo
sie uns niemand hier sieht uns jeder
wisst ihr was ihr nächstes glas
einschenken sieht man ganz gut
oder von der seiner form sein dass ich
gehen auch hier müssen sie doch einfach
zwei gläser install ok erstes glas hier
so kosmehl ohne essen und jetzt hier das
nächste glas einschenken müssen gleich
ins pause menü ich dachte gerade nur
welche pausen irgendwas macht wenn ich
sicher alter
das ist richtig viel merkt schon wie
sich mein bauch fühlt
ok ok ja das ist echt eine menge so viel
wie change sollte man nicht in einer 65
64 65 jahre 64er runde machen das kann
richtig nach hinten losgehen branche
immer voll macht einfach so zehn kisten
á la rosa muss sein zehn gläser wasser
trinke ich meine sind 03 gläserne also
ich habe jetzt drei getrunken als 0 9
litern wasser das ist auch schon
ordentlich innerhalb von 3-4 minuten
aber schäfer feuer macht es in der
großen runde 18 kills und trinknapf
enthalten viertelstunde drei liter
wasser das ist schon kritisch das kann
geht schon wahrscheinlich fast in die
gesundheitsschäden schilder
gesundheitsschädlich ist schlimmer als
schädlicher richtung kann ich auf
deutschland wo den holt aber in hohem
maß voll
nein aber das ding aber glaub ich noch
geblockt oder wenn ich eines mega alter
kommt einen fall noch hinter uns ist
keiner der fehlt uns holen
der kann eigentlich gar nicht so viel
leben haben ist ich glaube nicht dass
regeneriert du musst dich denn das essen
wenn er was ist würde ich sagen hab ich
da mal kurz rein da ist etwas und reifen
und redet ja ok nahm ihn sehr schön
heißt das nächste glas kommt sogleich
müssen wir hier was essen in game und
sehr schnell wieder dahin kommt wo die
lakers austauschen wenn die bessere
ganzen provinz dafür nicht auch conti
hat der nächste muss man das glas
einschenken ligaauftakt das blog top 50
ja ja okay die hammer ich dachte okay
leute
nein da kommt doch eine ich muss es
einfach jetzt schon zwei gläser wasser
trinken biogas alter noch zwei pfeile
ich schenke mir schon mal 1 1
während er darüber steht sieht man sieht
man ich muss aufpassen dass ich jetzt
nicht am glas vorbei was schütte auf die
tastatur oder kommt er jetzt kurz laufen
da komme ich ans ran
alter schwede heißt okay wir jetzt zwei
gläser wasser noch ausstehen zwei gläser
mit zehn leute alter okay bis was wir
tragen das kurz mal kurz weg
bleib du mal kurz weg damit starteten
zehn sekunden okay sagte der künstler
greifen ja
alter das ist echt extrem viel
also mir leute ganz ehrlich mir wird
jetzt persönlich gerade in diesem moment
übel nach dem vierten glas wasser ich
hab mir immer noch mal 1 1
ich muss langsam machen also eigentlich
weder das so eine menge gesagt ist ein
1,2 liter wasser in so einer kurzen zeit
das ist schon heavy vornehmlich gerade
erst gegessen habe bams an
ok ich dachte die change wer leichter
ist sie nicht die neulich ist kenntnis
keine chance wenn ich jetzt noch ein
glas echsen würde würde nicht gehen es
wird nicht gehen ich mich würde mal
leiser machen
das ist echt happy x change ist echt her
wie das sollte man nicht überschätzen
das ist ein schwert nicht schlecht nicht
schlecht kein schwerer für uns wir
müssen zwischen glas wasser rein
bekommen
er macht viel schaden der junge macht
echt viel schaden
jetzt haben die tamilen termin junge
alter sie zwei gläser bier trinken mehr
leute das ist zu hell wie das geht nicht
ist hier nicht das war es aber soweit
fertig haben die sehr gut beschritten
würde ich sagen wenn die runde gewonnen
ja aber ganz ehrlich mal es macht keinen
sinn wenn mir das total übel wird er von
welches eine bläser trinkt ist hilft
niemandem ich denke das video war auch
ohne dass ich gekotzt sehr interessant
und wir sehen zum nächsten video wieder
biss dann macht's gut und